meine verehrten damen und herren
bevor ich zum anlass der heutigen
pressekonferenz komme möchte ich mich zu
einem sehr sehr aktuellen thema äußern
corona ist nach wie vor nicht besiegt
leider
tag für tag ein und neue rekorde was die
zahl der infektionen angeht auch wenn
durch die impfung viele verläufen
deutlich milder geworden sind werden in
einigen regionen auch mehr mehr
infizierte in krankenhäusern aufgenommen
die intensivstation geraten mancherorts
an belastungsgrenzen
die lage ist ernst
die künftige bundesregierung hat
gemeinsam mit den ländern vergangene
woche entschiedene schritte veranlasst
um das pandemie geschehen ein zu denken
diese maßnahmen sind heute in kraft
entscheidend es nun eine konsequente
umsetzung der regeln zu 2g und 2g plus
im öffentlichen raum um die
infektionszahlen zu senken
nur wer geimpft oder genesen
gegebenenfalls über einen aktuellen test
abgesichert ist sollte zur veranstaltung
im restaurant und bars zutritt erhalten
so wie heute zu dieser pressekonferenz
am arbeitsplatz und im öffentlichen
verkehr gilt seit heute die dreijährige
um infektionen zu verringern
was für veranstaltungen
restaurantbesuche und bei der arbeit
gilt
sollten wir möglichst auch bei privaten
begegnungen selbst beherzigen impfen und
tagesaktuell testen um uns und unsere
lieben zu schützen
über diese beschlüsse hinaus wird die
neue bundesregierung des weiteren
veranlassen ersten
ständigen bund länder krisenstab im
bundeskanzleramt einzurichten er wird
die lage kontinuierlich gutachten und
beobachten und die umsetzung der
beschlüsse prüfen
zweitens
eine expertengruppe im kanzleramt
einzurichten die eine tägliche
beurteilung der korona lage vornimmt und
an die regierung gerichtet
darunter virologen
epidemiologen soziologen und psychologen
und weitere fachleute wir brauchen
diesen wissenschaftlichen sachverstand
um zu klugen erkenntnissen zu kommen es
geht darum die lage eng zu beobachten
die wirkung von maßnahmen zu überprüfen
und gegebenenfalls weitere schritte zu
entwickeln
drittens
die impfkampagne weiter massiv voran zu
bringen und die kapazitäten der
impfzentren noch deutlicher auszuweiten
wir wollen mit mobilen teams in den
städten und regionen unterwegs seien und
auch ärzte und apotheken stärker
einbinden auch den einsatz der
bundeswehr im dienst halte ich für
richtig wir müssen impfen und postern um
die verbreitung des virus zu erschweren
viertens die beschlossenen impfung zum
schutz von wohlhabenden gruppen müssen
konsequent durchgesetzt werden um zb
alten und pflegeheime besser zu schützen
fünftens für die besonders geforderten
pflegekräfte in den krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen werden wir eine bonus
zahlung veranlassen die ampel koalition
hat sich darauf verständigt für diesen
pflege bonus erst einmal eine milliarde
bereitzustellen
impfen ist der ausweg aus dieser
pandemie in einrichtung in den besonders
wohlhabende gruppen betreut werden
sollten wir die impfung verpflichtend
machen eine ausweitung dieser regelung
bleibt zu prüfen
siebtens die mpk beschlüsse so
rechtzeitig zu überprüfen dass wir
gegebenenfalls weitere maßnahmen beim
nächsten treffen der ministerpräsident
und ministerpräsidenten der länder mit
der bundesregierung beschließen können
meine damen und herren ich
weiß wir hatten alle die hoffnung dass
dieser winter kein corona winter werden
musste doch trotz impfung sind wir noch
nicht durch wir müssen uns abermals
zusammen nehmen die hygieneregeln
beachten abstand halten und die masten
pflicht beherzigen um einigermaßen heil
durchzukommen
gemeinsam haben wir es in der hand diese
schlimme vierte welle zu brechen die
neue bundesregierung wird alles
erforderliche tun um unser land gut
durch diese zeit zu bringen
und damit komme ich zum eigentlichen
anlass für unsere pressekonferenz zum
abschluss der koalitionsberatungen
meine wichtigste botschaft dazu lautet
die ampel steht
spd grüne und fdp haben sich in den
verhandlungen auf einen gemeinsamen
koalitionsvertrag verständigt und damit
auf ein neues regierungsbündnis
diesen vertrag legen wir nun unseren
parteien zur abstimmung vor und wir
werben intensiv dafür dass alle drei
parteien diesen vertrag in den nächsten
zehn tagen zustimmen werden
unser ziel ist das erste bündnis von rot
grün und gelb auf bundesebene zu führen
eine koalition auf augenhöhe mit drei
partnern die ihre stärken einbringen zum
wohle unseres landes
und sein der glaube an den fortschritt
und daran dass politik etwas gutes
bewirken kann uns eint der wille das
land besser zu machen es voran zu
bringen und es beisammen zu halten
es geht uns nicht um eine politik des
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners sondern um
eine politik der großen wirkung
wir wollen uns etwas zutrauen beim
klimaschutz beim umbau unserer industrie
bei der modernisierung des landes bei
der stärkung des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalts
wir wollen mehr fortschritt wagen mit
ehrgeiz und beharrlichkeit werden wir
unser land zum vorreiter beim
klimaschutz machen mit dem konsequenten
und zügigen ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien mit einer beschleunigung des
planungsrechts die industrie
unterstützen wir beim umstieg auf
klimaneutrale produktion
spitzentechnologie made in germany wird
es auch in zukunft geben
im wahlkampf habe ich viel über respekt
gesprochen ein respekt der eine menge
mit anerkennung zu tun hat aber dort
nicht verraten ich bin froh dass wir
miteinander vereinbart haben den
mindestlohn in einem schritt auf 12 euro
zu erhöhen wie ich es angekündigt habe
das bedeutet eine gehaltserhöhung für
zehn millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
wir führen die kindergrundsicherung ein
die armut verhindern und bessere chancen
für kinder und jugendliche schaffen wird
zugleich halten wir die rente wie
versprochen stabil und entwickeln sie
fort
und wir haben miteinander vereinbart im
kampf gegen hohe mieten den wohnungsbau
voran zu treiben 400.000 neue wohnungen
pro jahr davon 100.000 öffentlich
gefördert werden wir bauen
die modernisierung unseres landes gibt
es nicht zum nulltarif
wir werden massiv investieren um
deutschland in der weltspitze zu halten
diese investitionen haben wir
miteinander vereinbart und dabei werden
wir die schuldenbremse einhalten die im
grundgesetz garantiert ist
ein souveränes europa ist der schlüssel
und für unsere außenpolitik als
wirtschaftlich starkes und
bevölkerungsreichstes land im herzen
europas ist es unsere aufgabe
dieses souveräne europa zu ermöglichen
zu fördern und voranzubringen
die freundschaft zu frankreich
die partnerschaft mit den vereinigten
staaten und der einsatz für frieden und
wohlstand in der welt sind die säulen
auf denen unsere außenpolitik fust und
nun lassen sie mich noch ein paar sätze
sagen zu den verhandlungen der
vergangenen wochen die sie ja eigentlich
von ferne verfolgen konnten wofür ich
mich nicht entschuldigen möchte
in diesen tagen und wochen haben wir eng
intensiv und mitunter leidenschaftlich
vor allem aber vertrauensvoll
miteinander verhandelt alle drei
parteien seien es die grünen angeführt
von annalena baerbock und robert habeck
die liberalen von christian lindner oder
die spd mit saskia esken und norbert
walter borjans alle haben diese
gespräche mit großem engagement geführt
konstruktiv und immer lösungsorientiert
angetrieben vom willen das land gut zu
regieren und es voran zu bringen
das hat mir gut gefallen und in mir das
gefühl verstärkt dass hier tatsächlich
etwas zusammengewachsen und wachsen ist
in der koalition
die erste verkehrsampel ist im jahre
1924 in berlin errichtet worden am
potsdamer platz
damals zunächst noch eine ungewöhnliche
technik kann das funktionieren
haben die leute skeptisch gefragt
heute ist die ampel nicht mehr
wegzudenken wenn es darum geht die dinge
klar zu regeln und für die richtige
orientierung zu sorgen und dafür dass
alle zügig und sicher vorankommen
mein anspruch als bundeskanzler ist es
dass dieses ampelbündnis eine ähnlich
wegweisende rolle für deutschland
spielen wird schön danke
[Applaus]
ich warte sie noch auf den applaus und
dann kann man verspätet also sehr
geehrte damen und herren auch von
unserer von meiner seite guten tag und
herzlich willkommen während wir
verhandelt haben olaf scholz hat eben
den stil der verhandlungen ein bisschen
beschrieben haben sich einige krisen
dramatisch zugespitzt und entwickelt die
situation an den außengrenzen in belarus
aber eben vor allem die korona pandemie
und während wir um worte und
interpretation gerungen haben ist sorge
und angst in deutschland umgegangen
menschen stehen den schlangen warten auf
die booster impfung impfung und gehen
dann unverrichteter dinge wieder weg wir
übernehmen oder werden die regierung in
einer zeit der krise übernehmen und wir
sind uns nicht in urlaub scholz dankbar
dass er das eben noch einmal so
ausgeführt hat klar darüber dass wir
alles notwendige tun werden um die
vierte welle zu brechen und die krone
pandemie beherrschbar zu halten
in einer zeit wo so viel sorge angst und
verunsicherung da ist es ist wichtig
dass wenigstens ab und zu ein zeichen
ein dokument in diesem fall des mutes
und der zuversicht gegeben wird und ein
solches liegen wir ihnen hiermit heute
vor
das leitbild dieser regierung ist eine
handelnde gesellschaften investieren der
staat und ein deutschland das
schlichtweg funktioniert
die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
die industrie stärkste nation europas
bekommt eine neue regierung eine
regierung die es in der konstellation
nicht gab die sich gefunden hat und
weiter finden wird
ein land in einer zeit der krise zu
modernisieren bedeutet eine große
anstrengung und eine große
entschlossenheit ist notwendig
grundlage für diese anstrengung und
geschlossenheit die haben wir jetzt
geschaffen und im kern dieser neuen
geschichte die wir zusammen schreiben
können ist die vereinbarkeit von
wohlstand und klimaschutz wie ein roter
faden zieht sich der gedanke durch das
gegensätze durch eine neue politik sich
ergänzen können überwunden werden können
am massivsten wahrscheinlich zu
beobachten bei dem verhältnis zwischen
wohlstand und wachstum und dem schutz
des klimas und der natürlichen
ressourcen wir haben darüber gestritten
ob wir die klimaschutzziele in
deutschland die der groko dass bis 2030
die co2 emissionen um 65 prozent gesenkt
werden sollen noch anheben können und
haben uns dagegen entschieden dass in
den koalitionsvertrag reinzuschreiben
wir haben stattdessen einen anderen weg
gewählt nicht also immer größere ziele
zu beschreiben und zu ernennen aber in
der wirklichkeit immer hinter den
gesteckten zielen zurück zu bleiben
sondern konkrete maßnahmen zu
identifizieren wie wir die ziele
erreichen können solche maßnahmen sind
aus moderner bahre energien auf 80%
maßnahmen dass der co2 preis der
zertifikate nicht unter 60 euro fällt
was bedeutet dass der kohleausstieg
vorgezogen werden wird dass die
erneuerbaren energien nicht mehr ein
zusatz sind sondern im öffentlichen
interesse stehen dass sie die
versorgungssicherheit zu tragen haben
und nun habe nachgerechnet und sehen
dass wir mit all den maßnahmen die wir
beschlossen haben über die 65 prozent
hinaus gegangen sind wir sind auf 15
grad fahrt mit diesem koalitionsvertrag
der geist der dahinter steht ist in der
wirklichkeit zu agieren in diesem fall
natürlich erst einmal einen leitfaden zu
schreiben in der wirklichkeit zu agieren
und dann in der gegenwart das
bestmögliche zu tun auch die zweite
große ökologische krise unserer zeit es
adressiert wir haben das artensterben
und das höfesterben ist schreit nach
einem neuen denken in einer
landwirtschaftspolitik die nicht nur
wachse oder weiche kennt und was finden
wir in diesem koalitionsvertrag
die roadmap genau da hin zu kommen mehr
ökolandbau reduktion von pestiziden
förderung der bäuerlichen betriebe beim
umbau der tierhaltung und so versöhnlich
wir den gegensatz von schützen und
nutzen durch eine neue politik sehr
geehrte damen und herren
christian oder anna lena
saskia und nord es war manchmal ganz
schön anstrengend
wir haben uns ganz schön viel zugemutet
aber wir werden eine regierung sein die
auch anderen menschen etwas zumutet also
müssen wir uns auch etwas zumuten die
entscheidenden momente bei diesen
verhandlungen war waren immer dann wenn
man voneinander gelernt hat nachdem man
sich seine programmpunkte vorgetragen
hat und gesagt hat wie continue so hoch
sein dass nicht zu verstehen dass hp
jetzt schon seit 20 jahren gehört hört
endlich mal zu und die lautstärke wurde
immer größer gab es manchmal momente wo
es gekippt ist und man den hintergrund
der argumentation verstanden hat und
dann wurden neue lösungen möglich und so
löst sich vielleicht auch in dieser
ampel ein was wir für die gesellschaft
beschreiben gegensätze können überwunden
werden durch eine lernende politik ein
lernendes deutschland eine lernende
politik das ist das versprechen dass wir
uns gegen
[Applaus]
verehrte damen meine herren wir
übernehmen verantwortung für ein land
das in einer tiefen und noch nicht
überwundenen gesundheitskrise steckt wir
appellieren an alle menschen
sich impfen zu lassen oder sich um eine
auffrischung der impfung zu bemühen
bitte sie schränken sie in diesem herbst
und winter auch ihre persönlichen
kontakte ein
begrenzen sie sie auf das was nötig ist
damit wir alle in diesen schwierigen
zeiten
die freiheit der gesellschaft bewahren
und die gesundheit von uns allen
schützen können
das staatliche krisenmanagement der
künftigen bundesregierung
wird sich verändern es wird optimiert
aber es wird nicht weniger konsequent
sein um schaden von diesem land
abzuwenden
die gesundheitskrise ist eine aktuelle
herausforderung für die künftige
bundesregierung
aber wir haben auch bestehende
herausforderungen
denen wir uns widmen müssen
dekarbonisierung unseres lebens
digitalisierung des lebens die frage der
alterung der gesellschaft
das sind große aufgaben vor denen wir
gemeinsam stehen
wir spüren dass es in unserem land auch
den willen und den wunsch zur und nach
veränderung gibt
diese drei parteien haben in den
wahlkämpfen der vergangenen jahre ihre
unterschiedlichkeit nicht verborgen wenn
ich das einmal so sagen darf aber wir
haben uns in einem punkt
eine gemeinsamkeit erhalten nämlich den
status quo überwinden zu wollen wir
haben gemeinsam einen auftrag dieses
land zu modernisieren
insbesondere auch die junge generation
hat uns beauftragt diesen status quo der
vergangenen jahre zu überwinden
wir haben jetzt intensiv miteinander
gesprochen
die gespräche waren sehr diskret
außergewöhnlich diskret für die
politische kultur unseres landes der
letzten jahre ich versichere ihnen die
gespräche waren genau so kontrovers wie
sie diskret war
um einzelne sätze haben wir teilweise
stunden gerungen
sozialdemokraten und grüne können jetzt
stolz sein auf das was sie in diesem
koalitionsvertrag hineinverhandelt haben
das waren starke verhandler guten
argumenten ich glaube dass unsere
zukünftigen partner in der
ampelkoalition
in ihren parteien mit besten argumenten
für dieses verhandlungsergebnis werben
können für die fdp will ich sagen dass
wir auch unsere beiträge zum gelingen
leisten werden und dass die gremien der
fdp die heute über den koalitionsvertrag
beraten haben mit dem ergebnis ebenfalls
zufrieden sind was jetzt gebildet wird
ist eine regierung der mitte
die das land nach vorn führt
wir bilden eine koalition in der sich
die drei partner nicht begrenzen durch
das was unvereinbar in den programmen
war sondern wir erweitern und weil jede
politische kraft natürlich auch blinde
flecken hat wir sind also keine
koalition des ausschließen sondern der
komplementären politik
erreicht worden ist erstens dass
deutschland weiter anwalts solider
finanzen bleibt gerade angesichts der
sorgen vieler menschen um geldentwertung
ist dies wichtig es gelegt die breite
mitte des landes durch unterschiedliche
maßnahmen zu entlasten ohne dass es zu
belastungen an anderer stelle kommt
zweitens es gibt in unserem land sowie
private initiative privates know how und
privates kapital
das wir nun endlich entfesseln wollen um
unseren weg fortzusetzen in einer
dekarbonisierung digitalisierte
technologie nation die in der lage ist
wohlstand und wachstum für mehr menschen
zu organisieren
wir werden diesen staat digitalisieren
viertens wir bemühen uns in bester
anknüpfung übrigens an die sozial
liberale koalition der siebziger jahre
um die verbesserung der bildung und der
sozialen aufstiegs chance in unserem
land eines der versprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft was dringend erneuert
werden muss fünftens wir stehen für eine
gesellschaftspolitische liberalisierung
vielfalt individualität
das verbindet uns
diese fünf punkte beschreiben
trendwenden wo wir neues wagen einen
aufbruch organisieren wollen
aber es gibt auch kontinuität dinge die
sich nicht verändern die uns gemeinsam
wichtig sind
die bundesrepublik deutschland wird auch
mit einer ampelkoalition
ein verlässlicher partner bleiben im
westlichen bündnis
in der europäischen union
und in der gemeinschaft demokratische
rechtsstaaten auf der welt
wir haben außerordentlich ambitionierte
vorhaben wenn sie den koalitionsvertrag
im einzelnen auswerten werden sie das
lesen wir haben außerordentlich
ambitionierte vorhaben und deshalb
spüren der demut
angesichts der dimension dessen was wir
uns vorgenommen haben
diese demut ist ratsam angesichts der
herausforderungen wir werden diese
vorhaben auch nicht alleine umsetzen
können wir sind angewiesen auf die
unterstützung aus der gesellschaft aus
der wirtschaft und wir werden auch die
unterstützung derjenigen brauchen die
diese koalition nicht gewählt haben und
die sich zukünftig in der
oppositionsrolle wiederfinden
wir haben während der verhandlungen olaf
scholz neu kennengelernt
natürlich kannten wir ihnen aus seinen
früheren staatsämtern
aus dem politischen meinungsstreit im
parlament zu malen wir haben ihn aber
neu kennengelernt während der
verhandlungen wir haben ihnen erlebt als
eine starke führungspersönlichkeit
die über die erfahrung und
professionalität
verfügt dieses land in eine gute zukunft
zu leiten vor allen dingen aber haben
wir seine innere haltung erlebt und muss
mit egon bahr zu sagen olaf scholz
verfügt über ein inneres geländer
um aus einer klaren werthaltung heraus
dieses land nach vorne zu führen und
weit mehr menschen zu repräsentieren als
nur sozialdemokratisch grün oder liberal
gewählt haben und deshalb wird olaf
scholz ein starker bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland sein
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ist es so ok bitte bitte
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren in
nicht einfachen zeiten schaffen wir ein
bündnis das anspruchsvoll ist dass sich
aber nicht versteckt vor den großen
herausforderungen vor den krisen sondern
die chancen in dieser zeit sieht und
deswegen haben wir in den letzten wochen
gemeinsam gelungen danke für das
verständnis
dass wir das wirklich intensiv gemacht
haben weil wir einen neuen aufbruch
vorschob fortschritt schaffen wollen und
uns in dieser zeit nicht leisten können
hinter mauern zu verstecken und den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner zu suchen
sondern wirklich in den entscheidenden
bereichen dieses landes ein
paradigmenwechsel einzuleiten den es
braucht für die modernisierung unseres
landes für die modernisierung unseres
staates und vor allen dingen für den
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
und wir haben für die größte
herausforderung unserer zeit die
klimakrise mit diesem gemeinsamen
koalitionsentwurf den wir jetzt unseren
parteien vorlegen
den weg dafür bereitet dass wir als eine
der größten industrienationen der welt
klimaneutral werden können und zwar
klimaneutral im herzen europas gemeinsam
mit unseren europäischen
nachbarn und freunden und so wie wir vor
20 jahren mit erneuerbaren energien
eine neue technologie in die welt
gebracht haben die nicht nur eine
technologie war sondern die die
energiepolitik aber auch die
internationale zusammenarbeit verändert
hat ist das jetzt ein paradigmenwechsel
wo wir die wirtschaft auch
klimaneutralität stellen können und das
gemeinsam als beitrag für mehr
sicherheit in der welt
den weg bringen können und deswegen
haben wir einen
koalitionsentwurf geschaffen wo sich
diese frage der klimaneutralität durch
alle bereiche des koalitionsvertrages
durchzieht von der umweltpolitik über
die landwirtschaft die verkehrspolitik
die industrie und wirtschaftspolitik
aber eben auch die internationale
zusammenarbeit und außen und
sicherheitspolitik und das bedeutet auch
dass die frage einer gemeinsamen
klimapolitik eine europäische antwort
bedarf und vor allen dingen einer
aktiven energie und außenpolitik bedarf
um diese krise große menschheitsaufgabe
gemeinsam anzugehen und wir erleben
gerade dass wir diese gemeinsame aufgabe
in einer zeit angehen wo die krisen auch
um uns herum im direkten umfeld mitten
in europa schwerer werden wo die
herausforderungen schwerer werden werden
wir die situation in belarus sehen wenn
wir die situation an den außengrenzen
europas sehen daher haben wir uns
gemeinsam darauf verständigt wieder zu
einer aktiven europäischen
außenpolitik
zurückzukommen die auf die stärke der
diplomatie und des dialoges setzt und
auf eine werte- und menschenrechts
geleitete gemeinsame diplomatie
ein anderer großer paradigmenwechsel in
diesem papier ist dass wir
nicht immer nur alles aus der sichtweise
von erwachsenen sehen sondern dass wir
eine regierung bilden für die vielfalt
unserer gesellschaft eine regierung
unter samt viele familien unserem land
in dieser corona pandemie immer wieder
gespürt die auch die kleinsten und
jüngsten die kinder und die jugendlichen
die jungen menschen in unserem land
sieht und versteht dass kinder keine
kleinen erwachsenen sind sondern kinder
eigene rechte haben und
entsprechend sind vier projekte
verankert wie eine kindergrundsicherung
die ein wirkliches umdenken nicht nur
der sozialpolitik bedeutet in dem man
kinder aus dem hartz iv system
herausholt wo eigentlich kindern die
rein gehört haben sondern indem man
kinder und jugendliche eine andere
bedeutung in dieser zukünftigen
bundesregierung gibt und das als beitrag
zu einer generationenübergreifenden
politik die nicht jede einzelne gruppe
für sich sieht sondern die vielfalt in
der gesellschaft als stärker begreift
und auch für die vielfalt dieser
gesellschaft gemeinsam politik macht und
da ist die konstellation die ja einige
von uns gerade schon angesprochen haben
dass wir auch nicht eine homogene gruppe
sind wo immer alle schon
wissen dass sie 100 prozent recht haben
sich zu 100 prozent durchsetzen nein
sondern in einer dreier konstellation
kann sich niemand zu 100 prozent
durchsetzen
was aber eine möglichkeit gibt auch mal
den standpunkt zu wechseln und zu
verstehen dass wenn christian lindner
eine 6 auf der seite sieht und welche
einen neuen sehen dass wir vielleicht
beide recht haben können und wir nur
bereit sein müssen mal die sichtweise
des anderen anzunehmen und in einer zeit
wo soviel auch gegeneinander und
spaltung in der gesellschaft vorhanden
ist eine regierung zu bilden die bereit
ist den blickwinkel zu setzen und
gemeinsam lösungen und antworten zu
finden bedeutet für uns auch eine
modernisierung des gesellschaftlichen
vertrages eine modernisierung des
staatsbürgerschaftsrechts eine
modernisierung des familienrechts die
auf der höhe des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert ist und dafür schaffen wir
hier gemeinsam die grundlage und auch
von meiner seite herzlichen dank riechen
und diejenigen die hier auf der bühne
stehen sondern sie haben sich ja gefragt
warum wir in messehallen unter anderem
getagt haben weil wir eben die vielfalt
auch unser parteien mit eingebracht
haben und mit hunderten von der
verhandlungen und verhandlern in
arbeitsgruppen gesprochen haben und auch
von denjenigen an dieser stelle
herzlichen dank genauso an diejenigen
menschen die sich in dieser schwierigen
zeit an uns gewandt haben und deutlich
gemacht haben unsere erfahrungen in den
letzten anderthalb jahren corona
pandemie die müssen sich in einer neuen
regierung widerspiegeln und das hat olaf
scholz eingangs gesagt auch dass es die
erste aufgabe dieser neuen ampel
konstellation
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren ich bin mir sehr
gewiss wir haben mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag etwas auf die beine
gestellt das diesem land gut tun wird
wir haben in vielen langen gesprächen
das ist hier heute schon zum ausdruck
gekommen zum teil stundenlang über
einzelne sätze gerungen worden ist eines
gemeinsam gehabt als
ausgangsvoraussetzungen und das war eine
gemeinsame fortschritts erzählung das
heißt wir müssen in diesem land
schneller werden wir müssen dinge
anpacken wir brauchen einen aufbruch und
zwar nicht nur ökonomisch und ökologisch
wir brauchen ihn auch
gesellschaftspolitisch und diese
gemeinsame grundhaltung hat uns in
diesen gesprächen getragen nun weiß
jeder sind drei parteien die mit
durchaus unterschiedlichen blickwinkeln
auf diese gemeinsame thematik gucken und
wir wollten auch nicht fusionieren wir
wollen koalieren und deswegen war klar
dass man das gleiche große ziel mit
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen mit
unterschiedlichen instrumenten angeben
will und ich kann mich christian lindner
anschließend das haben wir nicht gemacht
indem wir uns mit unseren
unterschiedlichen instrumenten
gegenseitig blockiert haben sondern dass
wir uns gegenseitig bereichert haben
durch diese blickwinkel um eben etwas
zustande zu bringen das am ende allen
menschen in diesem land und nicht nur
unterschiedlichen partei anhängerschaft
nutzen soll ich glaube wenn man es jetzt
mal übersetzt was haben wir da gemacht
dann muss man sagen darf man sagen es
geht vor allem darum zu investieren
privat aber auch öffentlich in netze in
transformationen in
innovative projekte die uns voran
bringen digitalisierung und das ganze
eben immer in dem blick halten dass wir
es nicht nur mit der zukunftssicherung
zu tun haben sondern dass auch die
gegenwart der menschen betroffen ist als
die menschen mit kommen wollen bei dem
was sich ändern muss von dem wir alle
wissen dass sie sich aus ändern wird und
deswegen glaube ich auch wenn es dann
andere dinge gibt wo instrumente
die für uns eine größere rolle gespielt
haben so nicht am ende durch gekommen
sind ich sag mal eine stärkere belastung
ganz große einkommen und große vermögen
dann ist trotzdem gelungen dass wir viel
für kleine und mittlere einkommen haben
erreichen können gemeinsam erreichen
können ich nenne mindestlohn ich nenne
stabile renten ich nenne bezahlbares
wohnen und dass wir auf der anderen
seite auch klar gesagt haben das
gerechtigkeitsgefühl der menschen nicht
einseitig belastet zu werden hängt auch
sehr damit zusammen wie viel wir dagegen
unternehmen das sich andere vollkommen
aus der verantwortung stehlen wollen es
recht wenn es um steuerbetrug geht aber
eben auch wenn es um trickreiche
gestaltungen von steuern geht wir haben
über die mindeststeuer gesprochen wir
haben von der klaren einstellung zur
bekämpfung der geldwäsche gesprochen wir
haben und nicht nur gesprochen sondern
wir haben klare vereinbarungen dazu
getroffen welche institutionen wir
stärken müssen wir haben klar gesagt die
investitionen die wir brauchen kosten
geld dieses geld muss zur verfügung
stehen in dem wir die schuldenbremse
nutzen mit den möglichkeiten die sie
bietet indem wir andere institutionen
wie die kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau
oder förderbanken der länder und andere
nutzen um die investitionen möglich zu
machen und ich glaube wenn man sich das
gesamtpaket anguckt dann kann man sagen
dass dieser gemeinschaftliche blick auf
gegenwart und zukunft auf klimaschutz
soziale verantwortung förderungen der
lust auf innovation in diesem paket
enorm drin steckt und dass das echt
diese gemeinsame leistung ist durch das
austauschen auch unterschiedlicher
positionen das ausfechten
unterschiedlicher positionen und wenn
ich noch mal auf die gegenwart nur zu
sprechen komme dann sind wir nun mal mit
diesen diskussionen mitten in einer
gesundheitskrise die wir lösen müssen
und deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle
noch mal neben all denen die im
hintergrund und am verhandlungstisch
mitgeholfen haben zwei
ministerpräsidentinnen dann können die
hier vorne sitzen malu dreyer und
manuela schwesig die
ich finde in ganz wichtigen impuls
gegeben haben wie man runter kommen von
diesem was machen wir bei krone auf
zuruf sondern wie kommt man systematisch
dahin dass man wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse und politisches handeln in
übereinstimmung bringt und dafür waren
wir alle gemeinsam das darf ich glaube
ich sagen den beiden sehr dankbar
gestern abend dass wir auf diesem weg
eben auch zusammen ein stück
weiterkommen das hat wollen die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes und
ich glaube da zeigt sich auch direkt
schon im vorfeld welchen geist diese
koalition trägt welcher geist die
koalition trägt und ich will auch eine
bemerkung nutzung schluss machen für
mich ist das ein schlusspunkt ich habe
ihnen dankbar dafür dass ich mitwirken
konnte das wir auch als spd in diese
rolle kommen konnten eine regierung zu
bilden an diesen regierungsgesprächen
teilzunehmen ich bin dankbar dafür wie
wir zusammen gefunden haben zu etwas was
jetzt für mich ein schlusspunkt aber für
diese regierung für das land ein neuer
anfang ist und deswegen bin ich sehr
froh darüber diese zwei jahre habe
einsetzen zu können und werde mich jetzt
auf die position beziehen dass ich sage
jetzt kam dann mit anderen gucken was
draus wird der grundstein dafür ist
gelegt und ich freue mich sehr darüber
dass das so gelungen ist vielen dank
[Applaus]
wir haben eine sehr verehrten damen und
herren unser zukünftiger bundeskanzler
oder schulz lassen sie mich diese worte
noch mal genießen oder schuld also hat
ein anderer stelle mal gesagt hier ist
etwas zusammengewachsen in den letzten
wochen was zusammen passt und ich finde
das ist eine ganz kluge formulierung das
ist das was wir erlebt haben in den
letzten tagen und wochen wir haben sehr
sehr intensiv das ist schon gesagt
worden und sehr vertrauensvoll und
vertraulich zu manchem ärger miteinander
verhandelt so manches dazu gelernt nicht
nur über die beiden partner über die fdp
und über die über bündnis 90 die grünen
sondern auch über uns selbst weil wir
uns ja auch mit unseren eigenen
positionen auseinander setzen müssten um
eben auch wege zueinander zu finden und
das ist schon eine ganz besondere
leistung wir haben einen geschmiedet um
gemeinsam fortschritt zu wagen wir haben
aber auch verantwortung übernommen und
werden das auch weiterhin tun in der die
korona pandemie manche haben ist schon
gesagt das land und natürlich auch die
menschen stark belastet ihr vizekanzler
die ampel fraktionen ebenso wie die
parteispitzen waren und sind bereit
alles nötige zu tun um die gesundheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen
die bewältigung dieser pandemie in
angriff zu nehmen weiterhin was wir uns
für die zukunft vorgenommen haben
braucht viel mut wir wollen den wandel
in dem unser land in dem unsere welt
sich befindet aktiv gestalten die
dekarbonisierung ist angesprochen worden
die digitalisierung ist angesprochen
worden auch die demografie natürlich
eine wichtige herausforderung aber eben
auch die wachsende anerkennung von
vielfalt als chance für den zusammenhalt
in dieser gesellschaft dieser wandel
braucht nicht nur eine mutige regierung
wir alle müssen mutig sein neues zu
wagen und dafür brauchen wir freiheit
aber auch sicherheit und zusammenhalt
und daran werden wir gemeinsam arbeiten
wir verstehen uns bei all dem als
partner in europa und in einer welt die
vieles nur gemeinsam kann das gilt für
die pandemie und andere krisen das gilt
aber auch für die wandel
ereignisse über die ich gesprochen habe
wir sind drei partner auch dass es schon
gesagt worden mit sehr unterschiedlichen
traditionen und auch mit
unterschiedlichen grundhaltung und alle
drei hatten wir einen weg zu gehen um
zusammenzufinden
wir begründen finde ich mit diesen neuen
bündnis auch eine neue form der
zusammenarbeit die neugierde und die
offenheit die wir aufgebracht haben für
die sichtweisen die argumente und die
hagen herangehensweisen jeweils der
anderen das hat uns auch viele neue
perspektiven eröffnet ich finde das ist
eine chance auch für die politik
politische kultur in deutschland
das handelsblatt hat heute morgen haben
ein hesse zitiert und spricht von
gegnern die einander brauchen weil ohne
wind keine mühlen laufen das ist ein
schönes zitat und nicht als käuferin
möchte noch eins dazu führen fügen
nämlich dass aus dem stufen gedicht
allem anfang wohnt an jedem anfang wohnt
ein zauber inne das ist tatsächlich auch
etwas was ich heute empfinde das muss
ich ganz ehrlich so sagen wir sind
überzeugt dieser anfang ist uns gelungen
dieses bündnis steht für zukunft es ist
für die zukunft gemacht was wir uns
vorgenommen haben weist über die
legislatur hinaus und dafür legen wir
heute den grundstein für ein bündnis für
ein regierungsbündnis unter der führung
von bundeskanzler olaf schulz